[Music]
welcome to my review of the emoji movie
I have proof
the emoji movie is about the meth emoji
and how he has a lot of other
expressions
besides meth and today I wen saw it and
it's so despite the fact this is not a
hilarious 'ti review I'm sitting in my
hilarious Adi background because it just
felt applicable look I went to this
movie with just the slightest ounce of
optimism and I've seen some other
critics say this but ever since the lego
movie
I give movies the benefit of the doubt
sometimes when they seem like giant
product placement pieces of garbage and
sometimes I can be very naive because
that's exactly what this movie is let's
talk about it
TJ Miller voices the met emoji named
gene and he's about to go into his cube
now the cube is where everyone waits for
the user whoever owns the smartphone to
tap them so they can be zapped up into
the phone and sent through a text that's
their life their dream it's a world in
which all of the emojis live and
interacts but everyone must stick to
their one emotion other emotions beyond
what the emojis are created for that's a
no-no so when the other emojis
discovered the gene can create more
emotions than meth he becomes an outcast
I knew I was in trouble very early on
when meth says that emojis are the most
important form of communication ever
invented that's actually a line said in
this movie not the telephone just
emojis so all these emojis live on
Alex's phone and Alex is currently
having girl drama there's a girl at
school that he's crushing on he doesn't
know how to talk to her so he's trying
to figure out what emoji to send her
this is a major plot point and highly
important to the script we cut back to
that a lot the best thing I can say
about this movie is the fact that
Patrick Stewart plays the emoji poop he
has nothing funny to do in the movie but
I can say that Patrick Stewart plays
poop there's some novelty in saying that
to you yeah I'm poop here the more times
I can get you in this interview to stay
sure Patrick Stewart I'm poop the more
delighted I will be so gene is basically
forced to go on the run because he's
going to be deleted because he's so
weird he can show different emotions
that's where he meets jailbreak voiced
by Anna Faris and joining him on this
journey is hi-5 voiced by James Corden
every little bit of humor that you would
expect to have animu V like this is
exactly what you get it's all surface
level easy jokes jokes about the fact
that they're emojis they never try for
anything else beyond that it's also
filled with an assert amount of product
placement they go into various apps like
Facebook they mentioned Instagram you
see the Spotify app they fall into candy
crush they play an entire round on just
dance they take a ride on a blue bird
that looks like the Twitter logo and a
major integral plot point is that they
have to get to Dropbox they have to get
to Dropbox did you hear that come out of
my mouth it came Dropbox is important
plot point this movie
and know the experience of watching this
movie was not improved in any way when
they showed the YouTube app and children
in the audience went YouTube that didn't
help anything now Jean has parents who
of course are also met emojis
there's an entire subplot dedicated to
whether or not mom met and dad met will
split up or not because they're having
problems in their relationship this is
where we're at people sony has gone and
made the most unnecessary movie I've
seen in years
a movie about emojis and I went
and thought is money oh my god but you
know I've actually gotten a lot of
requests to review this movie so you
know this is that's that's how I justify
my actions I actually wrote down some
verbatim dialogue that's spoken in this
movie I'm just going to read it to you
and you guys can enjoy it what if you
get sent out on the phone and make the
wrong face you're so soft
poop the final resolution even for how
this movie ends and everything comes
together makes no sense even children in
this theater barely made a sound this is
one of the worst animated movies I've
seen in a really long time and it's
pointless there's really no reason for
this movie to exist small children will
be conscious while this movie plays
that's the best I can say about it guess
how it ends yep a dance sequence I'm
going to give the emoji movie and F did
you expect anything else guys thank you
so much as always for watching this
review I'll be back here on Sunday with
an actual hilarious tea review for a
Stephen King movie to start off my
Stephen King series you guys are the
best thanks again for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get
the nice
[Music]
you